well i don't trust red wings hold on a
minute you don't have to trust red wig
but i'm gonna go see if he's right cause
i have a feeling they might be a part of
the big three
what big three the big three white pick
three androids aliens and wizards
that's not a thing that's definitely no
it's not every time we fight we fight
one of the three so who are you fighting
now gandalf yep
how do you know about gandalf i read the
hobbit in 1937
when it first came out so you see my
point no i don't
there are no wizards dr strange is a
sorcerer
a sorcerer is a wizard without a hat
think about it right i'm right i just i
just came up with that it's crazy
look that's not the point these guys
aren't magical all right they use brute
force just like you
the incredibly annoying guy in front of
me with the staring problem i'm coming
with you no you're not
one minute two drop-offs and
ah
so what's our plan
great so no plan
30 seconds enjoy your ride buck no you
can't call me that
why not that's what steve called you
steve knew me longer and steve had a
plan
15 seconds to drop i have a plan
really what is it
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
mcu and yesterday marvel released two
exclusive clips for the falcon and the
winter soldier and there are a few
really important parts that we have to
talk about that happen in these clips
now i've seen episode one of the falcon
in the winter soldier and only episode
one so i just want to state that
neither of these scenes are in the first
episode so my breakdown of these two
scenes is not going to be because i know
what happens it's going to be my
speculation and tying things together
specifically the captain america call
back and the super soldier program
the first scene that they give us which
is part of the same scene but split into
two
it's pretty important because sam is
talking about the big three that he just
made up
androids aliens and wizards now what
he's talking about is the flax mashers
he's saying that they could be
a part of these big three but he says
that he doesn't think they're magical he
says that
they use brute force and we've seen the
flax masters kind of give bucky a run
for his money
and sam in several of the trailers and
clips that they've released now it's not
really mentioned
at any point in any of the clips that
they give us but we pretty much assume
that they are somewhat
some type of super soldiers that's why
they use brute force that's why they're
kind of kicking bucky's butt
who is indeed himself a super soldier so
it's widely believed that we're going to
explore the super soldier program
in the falcon in the winter soldier
which goes on to become the weapons plus
program and the weapons x program which
is responsible for
a lot of mutants so there's a lot that
goes behind this and it looks like we're
going to be getting into it because sam
goes to explore and of course
bucky follows which brings us into the
next scene the next scene
starts off with sam and bucky having a
staring contest much like the one that
we saw in the other trailer that marvel
studios gave us
now the reason they seem to be having
this staring contest is because they
have a mission
and sam has yet to come up with a plan
bucky is used to working with the
good old captain america steve rogers
who always had a plan and this scene
right here is actually a mirroring of
the scene from
the avengers with captain america and
iron man in the avengers scene when
they're on the quinjet
thor comes takes loki and leaves iron
man is about to go after him and steve
says
we need a plan of attack and tony says i
have a plan attack
therefore i don't really have a plan and
he jumps out and that's basically what
happens here
sam calls bucky buck and he says you
can't call me that because that's what
steve used to call me and remember that
falcon and sam
aren't really that close they're kind of
frenemies their connection
is steve they don't really have a
connection to each other on their own
steve always brought them together so
bucky's not that comfortable with sam
yet and says you can't call me that
because steve used to call me that he's
my best friend
and he had a plan sam says he has a plan
but then he jumps out the plane without
saying anything
and if you listen closely when sam jumps
out the window you can hear a little
repulsor blast much like iron man's
play the and you actually find out why
in the very first episode which is a
setup for everything that is about to
take place
in the falcon and the winter soldier so
those are the first scenes that marvel
has given us let me know what you think
about
them in the comments down below and let
me know how excited you are for the
upcoming show the falcon and the winter
soldier and do you think we'll see the
x-men be sure to subscribe for future
videos like this video if you enjoyed it
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof